right to Ukraine now and Germany's new
defense minister says he plans to visit
Ukraine in the next four weeks Berlin is
facing continued pressure to allow the
shipment of german-made leopard two
tanks to Ukraine recent talks in
Ramstein failed to convince Germany to
provide the battle tanks to Kiev let's
get the latest now from retired Air Vice
Marshals from belshawn thank you so much
um good to see you again Kimberly good
afternoon right let's talk about Germany
why are they so reticent to send these
tanks the pressure's been ramping up
hasn't it on on Germany and the danger
is it looks like they're being difficult
well actually the truth lies is it's far
from the truth the history as ever is
tied up in history at the end of the
second world war the Allies are
determined to make sure that Germany
could not actually Mount any further
Global Wars dismantle the German
military and but recognize they need to
have some defense the the Allies put
military bases across Germany in fact my
first tour was on one of them at RF
goodisloe in Germany and the recent
meeting of the world leaders was at
Ramstein and our EU South Military Base
in the middle of Germany of course then
the cold war came along and Germany
found itself at the front line of that
so the Allies relented allowed it to
build up its military capability but
they were absolutely firmly only on the
defense so the German military was not
allowed to collect Intelligence on any
of its people was not allowed to use the
military internally couldn't have
nuclear weapons and all of that was
enshrined in the Constitution likewise
for the German population those the two
World Wars cast a dark shadow across
their history so whilst they were very
content to help Ukraine with defensive
capability it's a completely different
issue to then start providing offensive
capability and the recent poll has
demonstrated that there's not widespread
for support for that no it's an
interesting one let's talk about Russia
a politician then also a close Ally of
Mr Vladimir Putin threatened that the if
the Western weapon deliveries go ahead
is going to lead to a global catastrophe
that's what he said I mean what do you
make of that sort of rhetoric the Putin
allian concerned is the ashes live
vladen here he's the speaker of the
lower house in in Russia very
threatening rhetoric but to be brutally
honest the last few days we've seen lots
of this sort of rhetoric all obliquely
referring to potential nuclear threats
the irony here of course is that Russia
is quite happy to threaten and invade
another country but as soon as it feels
threatened it starts to wail and and
moan about it the two main reasons why
this rhetoric though is ramped up is one
Russia recognizes that tanks could have
a decisive military capability in the
war particularly Western tanks uh could
be could prove decisive and secondly
they recognize the the Constitutional
challenge that Germany currently faces
and by ramping up the rhetoric make it
even more difficult for Germany to side
and support the deployment of Tanks now
Russia has also said that it's well it's
announced this major long-term expansion
to his Armed Forces what do you make of
that that was defense minister Sergey
shugu announcing a three-year shown here
three-year plan about one and a half
million it's even bigger expansion than
before another 11 bigger
um and it all the rhetoric was around an
increased threat from the West they're
also looking at putting a new uh Army
Core up in corellia there just off the
side of Finland almost certainly a
direct response to Finland acceding to
Nato membership and responding to that
threat more concerning though is
Russia's also not just about people it's
also mobilizing its defense industry
Putin has been talking to some of the
defense industry leaders uh trying to
get them onto a war footing with a
long-term strategy the real question
from my perspective is what's the West's
response to this up till now the West
has largely been providing what's
available in Military Support rather
than what's needed and raiding the sort
of West's War chests has served us
reasonably well for a year but it's
unlikely to prove a really good match
for Putin's long-term military strategy
okay Sean so much we'll see you in an
hour